first up eggs banks in hashbrowns the
secret of a great hash brown other
potatoes I prefer using really nice waxy
potatoes they cook better but more
importantly hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes we're actually gonna grate them
the potatoes get really nice and crispy
I mean seriously crispy now the onion
that way you have that nice balance of
the onion flavor running through every
little shard of potato seasoned with
salt pepper olive oil and kN give that a
really good mix through and then squeeze
all that water out look at all that
juice we've squeezed out a really
important the more liquid you remove the
crispier your hashbrowns will be nice
large pan put that on once the pans hot
pour in a good glug of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms how important it is
to have your pan nice and hot so it
seals the Greater potato onion together
to take the spoon and just Pat it down
what we're trying to do now is get it
really nice to compact
go around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter you just slip
them down the back gently and that gets
the onions caramelized here's a great
tip for turning your hashbrowns over
quick and easy take a plate place it on
top and just flip it over and then slide
it back in very quickly you see the
color we've got on there now that nice
crispy texture of the potato I'm going
to use the hash brown as our bed for my
baked eggs cracking your eggs nice and
gently just a little sprinkling of the
cayenne to make the eggs a little bit
spicy then into a preheated oven for six
to eight minutes meanwhile on to my
bacon and I'm giving it a classic
American twist now one thing I could
never get my head around when I first
started eating not American breakfast
was the sweetness from the bacon I've
grown up to love that combination of
smoky sweet flavors and it's so easy pan
on and simply heat olive oil
brown sugar salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistible caramelized and golden
brown tov the gas on my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful now my hash
browns and baked eggs are ready
go out beautiful just your spatula
underneath there onto your plate and
that bacon sits Beauty on top of the
baked egg on hash pan underneath and you
can see why the best breakfast in the
world are always in America
[Music]
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast eggs baton hashbrowns with
glazed bacon
[Music]